good morning John and happy birthday as
you can see this message is coming to
you from not just me
but also from over a thousand
nerdfighters who have taken pictures of
themselves doing the things that I did
in a video that I pre-prepared for you
those people then submitted images of
themselves doing all the things that I
am doing right now and with a little
application that Sam Raj and I invented
we're putting them all together into one
video starring thousands of people to
say one thing happy birthday John yeah
it's pretty cool so for example I can
reach over here and pick up a toy and
bring it back into the frame and here I
have a toy now it's going to be a
different toy for every person who
reaches for a toy but assuming that all
of the people who were doing this had a
toy they are now showing you their toy
and likewise I can reach over here and
show you my favorite book and all of
those people will then be showing you
their favorite book and I'm hoping that
there's a lot of Harry Potter's right
over here and I'm also hoping that
there's some John Green books and that
there's not so many Stephenie Meyer
books if you know what I mean and of
course since it is a birthday we're
celebrating it's important that I be
able to show you a party blower now this
might not be a party blower since I
assume not everyone has party blowers
lying around
you should have party blowers around but
I assume not everyone does so it may
just be something along and cylindrical
that's not a party blower like a pen but
no matter what it is when I blow on it
it's gonna be a celebration but John I
think best of all is that I could hold
up my happy birthday wishes to you and
people will be showing you their happy
birthday wishes on this piece of paper
all they have to do is get a piece of
paper and draw their happy birthday
wishes and you will be seeing all their
happy birthday wishes and they're doing
it because you're awesome and because
they like you so John from the bottom of
my heart and on behalf of all the people
in this video let me just say thank you
for being a great brother for being a
great video maker for being a great
person a great father a great author and
now of course very rapidly I will be
showing you all the amazing birthday
wishes that people sent you
[Music]
day you died was a good day
thousands of people wished you on your
way
but instead of being sad to see you go
thousands of people start in your
birthday video Oh goodbye 32 year old
John you travel a lot and you got
yourself a son and the a thought Snooki
all about serial commas and now you're
33 friends the love
you got really upset about balcony and
we found out you like pizza and that
became theme and you and I went to
xscape
and I'll lots of people made you llama
birthday cake so goodbye 32 year old
John you traveled a lot and you got
yourself a son and the SU talk Snooki
about serial commas and now you're 33
friends the llama
oh when they Eddie did some home
renovation we created VidCon an awesome
celebration you got people to plant
trees on my birthday and we sent a plane
to Haiti called the dftba Oh goodbye 32
year old John you traveled a lot and
you've got yourself a son and yes you
taught nokia about serial commas and now
you're 33 French the llama
oh the Netherlands almost won the World
Cup and the nerdfighters found you just
the bug and you published a book with
David Levithan and Margo Roth Spiegelman
travel all throughout the land Oh
goodbye 32 year old Johnny you travel a
lot and you've got yourself a Sun man
you startled to you about serial commas
and now you're 33 French the llama
[Music]
3433 friends full of
now you're 30
you